good morning children is it on is it on
is this [__] on good morning kids it's
Mommy I've missed you oh so much and I'm
so sorry for being so late to the party
now
word on the street as Rebecca is gonna
die and go to hell forever so if I do
all I want to say is I love you
and I'm forever you're a witch mother
goddess Supreme we love you too who
loves me too everybody nobody loves me I
have no one in life mark
nobody loves me but I love Mary Kate and
Ashley Olsen so
you wanna tell people what happened this
week
oh right some guy gave me Fentanyl
and because fentanyl is rat poison and
my penis is a rot tail I died
I died under a call Jacob sign a
fentanyl which is rat poison never do
Fentanyl because I wanted to kill myself
and then you would kill me but you asked
for fentanyl I heard no he gave it to me
he said he's giving it around and I was
like okay I'll take some too why not
it's hard to just die and see if it was
worth it it's hard to get a straight
story but uh [__] it [__] it okay fine
fine he gave it to me fine okay Narcan
you three times and save you he did so
thank you to him and it was twice don't
worry about not three times you were how
do you remember you were out
you were passed out narcon fire can do
what
what's that fire not as Arabic for fire
apparently fire can burn a witch
or it can take a little boy and turn him
into a [__] because obviously that's
what I think I deserve right for not
being enough of a woman yet for not
converting that womanism yet for having
failed at 25 to become a w-o-m-a-n at
the age of 25 right so Chinese things I
feel like I deserve to suffer in Hell
forever for failing crossover to
Womanhood
for instance you're young yet
those are your words not mine on the
olsenzo Barrington set I come bearing
gifts of apology to my audience
we haven't met yet and I don't know why
but you're right guys
I'm a fake [__] piece of [__] man
so if anyone has any advice out there or
can help me
become the woman that I wish to be
I recently read the news that Ellen Page
became a mom
I don't know if I personally approve a
lot I prefer Alan Page as a woman see
but I wouldn't judge him oh yeah boy
neither Rebecca
for what she has failed to do Rebecca
olsenzo like Roz from the Stafford wives
Air1 naturally alkaline spring water
could you imagine there was no water
anywhere
see I once saw a movie right just before
I left New York it was called Tales From
The Loop starring Julie Garner
she's also inventing Anna you know the
one where like um
where she goes to jail right because
over and above I have to length that
need to be cleared
that can be paid for it's fine horns for
what oh uh one's for indecent exposure
and um over and above like that can be
cleared I remember that well I haven't
arrested for it yet I asked the co-ops
today I swear if they were gonna arrest
me I was like arrest me Deport me they
were like no you're fine I'm like what
I've Torrence wonderful penis and one
for the fentanyl I think
I think either way really yeah Madame X
I mean every everyone's taking fentanyl
down there
there's like 90 of the headaches on Skid
Row are doing fentanyl I've done it
twice over and above I I'm trying to get
off the girls they don't want me there I
don't want to be there what was it like
to OD
terrible I couldn't feel a thing
actually I just remember waking up in in
the um you stopped breathing and they
had like tubes on my nose and down my
throat and in my arms and like I hadn't
even asked for it you know what I mean
so I just felt like I was going to hell
or something
and it just felt disgusting and then I
was thinking like I'm gonna go into the
tar set and I'm gonna sit into her
forever for failing to be a witch okay
I'm being punished and this is what I
deserve I'm dive on this
The Wall Street Journal
The Wall Street Journal magazine see the
Wall Street Journal was the first to
report that's the magazine on Mary Kate
and Ashley Olsen's billion dollar
evaluation for the row and legitimized
it
the first magazine not Vogue
and there's an article here about Lena I
mean what's his name sorry but you wait
wait Mark
just one more thing about the OD you you
went to the hospital I went there yeah
yeah yeah okay I went there to see you
and you were gone
um wait oh no I was there I just got out
yesterday oh you were there which
hospital do you go to uh Lena nerd
I went to lacusc LA General that's where
I went yeah I just got out yesterday
what was it what name were you under
Rebecca Olson oh that's why why did your
name becomes well now that I know your
real name yeah they don't see me under
that name I'm not that name no I hate
that name they said the last time that
person was there was in July or
something like that yeah of last year of
last year I used that name once again
anyway Charles big butt so there's an
article here about Lena Nair and she's
the new um CEO of Chanel she was working
at Unilever last
she masterminded the show out here you
know there was a shot you're a writer
Chanel show at Paramount Studios
I don't
there was a shell show up here on
students wait you don't know I don't I'm
telling Versace
Versace I don't run in circles
Versace and Celine came
and then you get money and I'll Uber you
back
wherever you want to go wherever I want
to go West Hollywood whatever you want
well first of all I'm going back just
Kidd Road to collect on some um I don't
want to call them dots
I want to call them
those and or
allowances and or O's
what is the value of arithmetic in life
what is the value of math
mind over matter or matter over math
Mind Over Matter over math how but I
mean so moth over mind over matter let
me interrupt for a second math over mind
over matter you were so close to death
here oh I wish the life that I live I
would rather be dead everyone would
rather me that apparently everyone hates
me for no reason I have no idea why
because I have a penis hey nobody hates
you everybody hates me nobody hates you
everyone hates me you don't know my life
there's a couple people find you
annoying but everybody hates me no
everybody should be like [__] no I think
you hit yourself and that's it I don't
hate myself I love myself so much well I
don't value myself that way I don't look
at myself like that but over and above
remember the end of Gone Girl when
chased herself in the head with with the
with the hammer like I couldn't even
bother to do that nobody lives a
lifestyle that you lead without
um she hit herself in the face with a
hammer
and I know for a fact
that Russell and Pike actually did do
that
they rehearsed it and she really did it
she was in that video right ever seen
that movie The Possession nope she's in
that video that recreated The Possession
starring Isabella Johnny which honestly
I don't want to say is one of my
favorites but I think it's very literal
to the sense of my failures in
Witchcraft and or my desolation into
hell and or apparently from 26 to 27
I've been promised things at 27 over and
above but um in my failures right The
Possession I think it was 1971 to 1983 I
can't remember
away it's a very simple story a woman
gets possessed by the devil and or roths
in hell like Persephone
I once got high outside uh uh bibimbap
or whatever as in my head
if the Rothschild family still exists
which they do what would they think of
me and you
here's looking you a kid that's what
they'd say and laughed their asses off
I'd say
at this little boy because I could [__]
with a big fish
like any other stranger out there in the
Stitch
this situation of total embarrassment I
mean I'm so so ashamed to be here truly
hey Mark I like your outfit you should
put it on Instagram
on Instagram
on God on skidra on God on Instagram on
Skid Row I think you're a genius I think
I'm
an idiot but the line between genius
Madness the line between genius and
Madness is a fine line dance break take
two drama club so this is my take two
I'm sorry excuse me my voice is a little
hoarse
Horst P Horst when I think of Nicole
Kidman I think of Horst the Horst
get a photo in Vogue right you're no
horse be horse I do okay so you're fine
they don't know horse pee horse
they're judging me I only know that one
photo right with the laundry I think
it's very Nicole Kidman and was that
Nicole Kidman photo you know the one
with her back yeah oh you do know that
photo Yeah Yeah by baz learning by Carla
I'm a photographer who died rest in
peace your book reminds me of his uh
little box jacket book styled by Karina
voice in which the book was printed in
black and then printed over in white
foreign
so either way I mean the Prince of
Darkness or I'm Persephone
or am I both
but Johnny won not Amber
you're winning not me
oh no I better don't when I give you
money today are you gonna spend it on
clothes or drugs both
me neither neither cigarettes and wigs
I'll go to wehound party
stun
none neither I'll spend it on cigarettes
and wigs
and cyanide
relax I don't know where to buy cyanide
are you suicidal no yes no yes yes and
no
I want an escape or at least I want a
second chance right like kind of like a
second coming or something it's not that
I'm suicidal it's the whole world
[__] hates me in part for no reason
half hates me half loves me and the half
that loves me sees me as a piece of [__]
right like person who truly deserves the
lowest you have no idea Mark who hates
you
various echelons of society does not
understand the pressures on one [__]
human being to deliver what
the creation of all witchcraft
deal
there are people in life who want to see
a little boy drown in a tar page do you
know what a tar pit is Mark
drown in a Target
over experience
a life of solitude and smoke
below the shop
those people
are watching listening right now
and truly hate me so there are two
cameras right love and hate let's say
Mary Kate and Ashley
and there's Elizabeth Elizabeth is
Arabic for she who tortured Elizabeth
I was wearing all reds eh and they put
me in Block I don't know why
but it's h m Windsor and fake Adidas let
me see what you're wearing I hate that
okay but I'm wearing pants today
very mad okay
see Mary Kate loves to wear
pants
and t-shirts I had a t-shirt that a mom
gave me and they made me take it off
over the Lebanese man give me a t-shirt
today and bless me and it said earned
not given
because my America my right to America
will be earned not given I wasn't given
a free pass in life I'm feeling illegal
nothing I have nothing I have no way to
earn money I have no way to breathe no
you do have ways no that's one thing no
Mark listen no I don't yes you do Mark
you don't know Mark it's only I was
thinking whether she was in me I have no
right to breathe
black people African-Americans in this
country are African Americans so they
are Americans I'm not an American I'm
simply an African I don't even have the
right to oxygen in this country I don't
deserve it because I'm not an American
all my Liberties and my rights in this
country I have earned not I just got off
my back but by my very own liberty
which is that very American existential
idea Liberty Liberty is an existential
idea in modern America
Liberty over slavery
so they wish me to be what they call a
Zeta slave a tar [__]
to mu and her forever instead I wish to
be liberated as a witch as a woman
as a slave no more
and yet I'd love to be even as little as
a slave to perform for um
chitlins and
wave
instead I got nothing and no one and I
have no one and nothing
and that's my compromise in life
[Music]
the Earth Cafe could be a hurt Cafe
and no one even recognizes the fragility
of the situation in life
you know I was asked here I saw the man
with with the gun right I was thinking
and I was thinking about the Mexican
wrestlers and remind me of the last
Jean-Paul gutier ready to wear show
which overlapped around me of Fergie's
um la love uh music video
we kind of explain a compromise which is
there are two hotels downtown the new
million dollar Rosslyn Hotel the new
Million Dollar Hotel and the Roslyn
hotel and both our hearts
and I have so much love for people I
would give millions of dollars away if I
could
[Music]
Daddy
bought her daddy someone just said Daddy
I think Who Owns My Heart
and I Can't Be Tamed Dottie come to
Daddy you're in a perky mood today
uh perky peachy [__] Keen perky
there's a fish in the percolator I'm
pretty much the Pete Martel of
Witchcraft is this clean this is not
clean I'm perfectly sober clean as [__]
I swear I'm so pissed off
I'm not drugged since I got to the
hospital technically I had one line last
night I am Stone Cold Sober Stone Cold
Steve Austin sober
doesn't give no name I'll just see your
system it's rat poisonwork don't you out
of anything I think it's worse than rat
poisoning
well we're definitely grateful for water
today a witch is grateful for water
thank you Mark for watering a witch
but back to Jennifer because I love
Jennifer
don't you ever talk [__] about her
she built her living off the back of
being [__] upon
not really funny girl
Barbra Streisand
you ever heard that song Duck Sauce
exactly
you're not Young And Hip like a mark
but neither am I I'm 26.
but I was promised 27 I'm sorry I'm work
I'm sorry I'm pissing you off today
because I'm not talking about the
overdose
sometimes
I don't wanna I don't even want to
misquote it right now like it's a hell
of what I'm about to go through for it
but
sometimes you wake up and you wish
you were going to kill yourself remember
Julianne Moore the hours yeah
I always feel that way that line always
resonated with me not Virginia Woolf
with the stones in her pocket fine I can
understand that not Meryl Streep
Julianne Moore truly resonated with me
sometimes you wake up
you feel like you're going to kill
yourself truly no real [__] on the
feminism that I'm not on this isn't
Sontag I haven't read yet
on over and above the fact that Johnny
Depp and [__] Donald Trump beat Amber
Heard and Hillary Clinton and yet I'm
being judged
do you know what dissociative
dissociative identity disorder yeah deal
do you have a d-i-doms on distress oh I
wish I could be reprogrammed as a Zeta
beta slave
as an MK I'll just leave absolutely deal
oh my God anything to do with the CIA I
would love
but it's very common yes in victims of
trauma and abuse so sometimes you tell
me nothing happened to you as a kid and
other times you tell me nothing happens
again no really nothing happens no
nothing happened to me as a kid there
was one video where you told me that
your dad did some [__] early on no he
didn't do some [__] that was weird no no
no no no no no no my mom did [__] I said
my mother not my father my mother beat
me my father never laid a handle me my
father is a good man he's my stepfather
but he's a good man oh my real dad well
whoever my dad is
he is forever
forgiven for his sins
sin is in apparently
oh my god um yeah he did [__] to me when
I was younger or did he or didn't he no
he didn't I swear to God he didn't and
don't you ever accuse him of doing that
no really he didn't but you said you and
look back at the videos I never said he
did I said my mother abused me my mother
beat me Savage I never said my father
did anything I'm gonna watch that
December 21 video watch pull it up right
now hold up right now I need to see this
pull up right now December 21st no no
December of 2021. I'm pulling up right
now pull it up right now I can't find it
pull it up right now yeah you can find
it yeah you can find it no no really you
can find out that I said my father
abused me
it's gonna take me too long to find but
let me try well then I guess I'll have
to deal with the sins of that my father
abused me a beautiful abusive weakness
yeah I was just like Rosemary to wet
honestly with a beard
do I look like a goat
Mark Twilight ago no you look handsome
in your short hair Mark do I look like a
[__] goat
oh my God Chad you're cheating on me
with a [__] goat
you're crazy I'm I wish
I'm stone cold sober
oh and I need that phone that you
promised me Daddy
oh downtown come see me tomorrow uh why
not today
I'm not downtown today
okay so pull up where it's Gonna Roll
okay
watch your videos
she trusts me I would you know what I
mean
I love you mark you're like my best
friend I wish we could spend more time
together but you're always working I
work a lot you work a lot everybody
contains that I work the situation in
Iraq I'll find it I'm gonna find it
right now you haven't found it yet Oh I
thought it was Breakfast at Tiffany's
and Jackie oh and they do Breakfast at
Tiffany's now well they do brunch at
Tiffany's I wonder if they're still
doing it or not there's a Tiffany had in
here
put up
gives the air
oh my gosh
are you barefoot no I left my clogs
right there mark
I wanted to buy those Gucci shoes but
they wouldn't give them to me Mark
wow wow
I'm just trying to pull up the um
oh [__]
what do you do for two days in the
hospital
it wasn't two days it was like four or
something
what's the one happened you wish you
could break salt I oversold things wow
so do I
the one theme from friends you will
never forget the finale last thing on
the show this really feels like the end
of friends to me
or maybe not well either way at the
beginning of friends did did the
fentanyl overdose make you reconsider
anything
maybe reconsider everything
like what
my oh 1837 legendary Diamond since 1837.
Tiffany and Co you don't want to talk
about it
it made me rethink that because it's by
Harry Winston girl but over and above
made me rethink um
maybe we think Andrew tarlow
all right you're done
you're not really
getting attention anymore pay attention
to what exactly